let's start off with a logical slide if
I can get my clicker clicker I just woke
up
it's nice to I mean it's really nice to
be no I'm from British Columbia and nice
you know no way in British Columbia we
got a lot of common right we got we both
serious about our mountains we live near
our oceans and you guys will find it's
amusing but it freaks the Australians
out but yeah this is a camera that I sit
between my house and my neighbor's place
we called the animal highway there's a
Greenbelt in behind and this is
Wednesday morning about 5:00 a.m.
Wednesdays is garbage day in my
neighborhood so he's just dropping by to
see if I put up my garbage early that's
all I didn't realize it's still up put
the camera in he's like there every week
and he's an optimist because I never put
my garbage out early
hello this bear he's a pretty good bear
he if you do put your garbage out early
he'll tend to just pop the can open and
take the bag and go into the ravine with
it so basically the bear takes your
garbage out for you that's a good bear
thanks so much for coming to see me my
name is Richard Campbell I wrote my
first line of code in 1977 now that's
not the most important thing to happen
in 1977 the most important thing to have
in 1977 was Star Wars
all right so let's we have our
priorities straight that computer was a
trs-80 model one it had a whole 4k a
memory I could set tape player for
storing programs on I was playing I
think that's Star Trek on there right
there
I was running a version of basic not
made by Microsoft it was actually a tiny
basic and it only had three error
messages what how and sorry which I
still think is the best error message
ever
what is object not found but sorry I
make a few podcasts any.net rocks
listeners oh wow awesome so my friend
Carl Franklin started Donna rocks back
in 2002 I was a guest in 2004 became
co-host in 2005 we're at 15 54 as of
yesterday so few shows I also make a
show for IT pros called run as radio
once a week every Wednesday since April
of 28 2007 and briefly for a few years
and it actually relates to the store
I'm about to tell we made a show called
the tablet show and I'll explain why
later so we're gonna talk a little bit
about Microsoft and it's fun to talk
about Microsoft if you use their logos
that's the 1977 Microsoft that's the
disco logo and of course this is when
Bill Gates drops out of Harvard to write
a version of basic for the EMSA 8800
they the Altair right from the very
beginning Microsoft was about
programming languages and they only copy
I could find at that original language
this is in the Computer History Museum
in San Jose and the app paper tape
version of it although this is actually
like the second edition is the 8k
version because new memory but it's
interesting to think in terms of
Microsoft started out as a programming
language company and what Bill's insight
was was at that time in the 70s software
came free with the hardware so when you
bought the hardware it came with
software it was a very good software and
every time you upgraded your hardware
replaced your hardware you needed all
new software they really had no
relationship with each other and so he
was trying to sell software separately
rather than get caught in that hardware
cycle and all the problems that were
happening there he started building
programming languages it would work
across hardware so if you learned how to
program in basic on the Altair you could
apply it to the Heathkit or on the Apple
2 you could apply to the terrace 80 mod
3 that was the idea now if you
fast-forward a little into the 1980s and
when we would argue Microsoft loses
their way and we can blame IBM for that
because there's this whole story about
how IBM needed an operating system for
their for their microcomputer the the 80
50 50 and so they went outside of the
organization to find that operating
system and they originally approached
kilgore the guy who made CPM and he
wasn't home that day he was out flying
his airplane instead and so then they
went to Bill and Bill said I'll get an
operating system and went and bought one
and then modified it became ms-dos and
suddenly Microsoft was an operating
systems company and well we all know
what happened from there
that ultimately morphed into Windows the
1990s version is where our story about
dotnet actually begins and it starts
with Visual Studio so if we back up to
1997 some more than 20 years ago
Microsoft had a whole host of different
programming languages that they were now
shipping they still made a version of
basic now they had their Visual Basic we
started in 91 but this is 97 so it's
they're actually fairly far down the
path version 5 they also made a
definitive version of C++ those resorted
their two biggest products they had
acquired foxpro and then we're still
shipping it in the box and they had made
a version of java called j + + and they
had their first attempt at web
development tool called inter dev and we
won't talk about that anymore
but each one of these programming
environments had its own editor its own
debugger its own environment and its own
interfaces hooks into windows and as
they got more and more of them it got
very expensive to maintain and so there
was this vision about creating a unified
development space this is what Visual
Studio is about it was a lie but it was
a good law because the unified UI that
we IDE that was actually a Visual Studio
was only used by inner dev and j + + vb
had its own c++ still had its own
Foxboro still had its own the next
version they put out they changed the
numbering system they went from years to
numbers they started with 6 because
numbers are hard and they remembered
everything to 6 now it was the 6 version
of Visual Basic so it was vb 6 and they
could make c++ look like a 6 it was
actually the second version of inner dev
and they called it 6 it was also the
last version of in a dev and nobody's
unhappy about that and it was the third
version of j + + which they also called
6 and it was also the last version to
that because Sun Microsystems got a
little upset with what Microsoft was
doing with their version of Java and
there was a lawsuit and they stopped
making their own version of Java but
still oh by the way still separate IDE s
for Visual Basic C++ Fox
they never did unify so it was a good
dream but it never actually came
together
the biggest issue really was that
interface to Windows Microsoft is
shipping new versions of Windows on a
regular basis in this era and these
ultimately are how we're viewing our
applications and so they want those new
features in Windows to appear in the
programming languages but each team has
its own runtime and so there's sort of a
battle about what features will be
surfaced and how they'll be surfaced and
the windows team does not like that but
let's take a little detour another
around other important things that are
happening this is in 1998 and I love
this picture it's a Getty picture they
both just look so darn happy don't they
and it's because they don't know what's
coming this is July of 98 and it's
really gonna hit the fan about a month
now we forget this is a long time ago
but there was a time when when Bill was
considered a master of the universe this
is a Time magazine cover from June of 95
when they were calling him literally the
master of the universe he had a goal of
putting a PC on every desktop and by 95
with win 95 he'd achieve this goal and
they were celebrating that but
fast-forward back to a month after that
Getty picture was taken in August of 98
and he's being deposed by a Senate
committee in the United States and if
you want you can watch this deposition
on YouTube it is there to watch bill
doesn't act very well in this he is
pretty dismissive of the Senate
community and now admittedly he is
talking to politicians so we know how
intelligent that whole conversation is
going to go but he didn't help himself
and this is the beginning of the
Department of Justice suit against him
that ultimately fines Microsoft to be a
pernicious monopoly that's the ultimate
charge and that's the kind magazine
cover in November of 99 very American
thing you know to take their heroes and
turn them down and now bust bill and I
won't deny for a moment that there was
Microsoft had acted in a monopolistic
way on certain behaviors you could
interpret them a variety away there were
many solution to this but ultimately the
case resulted in by November of 1999
Microsoft being declared a monopoly and
ordered to break up into two companies
an operating system company and in
everything else company now we know it
didn't happen but that was actually the
declaration and in January of 2000 this
is from the they look sadder now don't
they it's only been two years but this
is Bill stepping down as CEO Steve's
gonna take over Bill becomes chief
architect and Steve's first job is to
stop Microsoft from being broken up and
he will succeed it will take him almost
two years the consent decree will be
finalized in November of 2001 but in the
midst of all of that they've been
working on a new development environment
since since studio had shipped in 98
there was this whole discussion about
dealing with the problems that they were
having with all these different
programming languages nobody set out to
make dotnet they were all feeling around
for what we wanted to do for enterprise
development there were plenty of false
starts in different projects I've been
researching this for the past year and a
half there are many little projects it
existed inside of Microsoft at this time
they were all about trying to solve
enterprise development at scale and of
course Java was chugging along just fine
at this time and and being quite
successful so Microsoft's trying to find
a solution to didn't fall Maritimes was
talking about stuff like next-generation
Windows services which eventually came
next generation web services which
actually never became anything at all if
you really want to talk about what
becomes dotnet you talk about three
aspects so this is in the 97 98 time
frame three different people working on
three different problems and I'm going
to put faces to it but just understand
these represent hundreds even thousands
of people ultimately so the first aspect
is this runtime issue and it's Brian
Harry that actually takes on the runtime
issue he's put in place to figure out
how can we make a common runtime between
these different languages all servicing
features of Windows to programmers the
next aspect is led by anders hallsburg
now anders had originally come to
Microsoft from Borland
to build tooling for Java but since the
sun microsystems injunction had come in
place and Microsoft wasn't allowed to do
anything with Java at all
he was basically offered an opportunity
he'd never had before in his life to
build a new language from scratch and
urza's history had been taking existing
languages and making better versions of
it he did it with turbo Pascal I did it
with throw a basic they did it with
Delphi and he was working on Java and
now he was basically set offered do you
want to make a language attraction I
would also point out Microsoft did that
time did not make languages from scratch
either they made their own versions of
C++ and basic and and so forth and here
was this opportunity to actually make a
new language and so without language
would eventually become c-sharp it was
initially codenamed
cool as in C object-oriented language
and you'll still see if you look at some
of the old documentation this reference
to cool that's what they're talking
about so and finally mr. Guthrie Scott
joined Microsoft in 1997 graduated from
Duke University it is the only job he's
ever had he joins the visual studio team
under a guy named Mark Anders he's young
man he's in his he's in his 20s and they
ship Studio six and he was specifically
working on the NT option pack so is four
in November of 1990 are in November of
1997 and it's common practice in
Microsoft that after you have a major
version ship like that you take a couple
weeks off recharge the batteries get
ready for the next version that put him
into mid-december so most people took
the rest of December off too but not
Scott Scott didn't want to go home to
North Carolina he wanted to make a
better way to program on the web because
he did not like is and he certainly
didn't like active server pages and so
he hacked away for a month and I have
now actually seen his notebooks from
1997 when we were doing interviews
around putting this book together he
produced the book the notebook so 1987
with his handwritten notes of exactly
these problems and in January of 98 he
shows off to the team a prototype what
would he called ASP plus at the time and
the scripting language is Java
because c-sharp doesn't exist yet and
they go this is really cool
you can't use Java so they that's the
beginning of all of that so but these
three aspects the runtime the interface
two windows a language some way to
program in and web you know we are in
the late nineties early aughts and the
Internet is a big thing and so we're
trying to get better ways to program
against the web those are the three
aspects that come together to eventually
be called dotnet the first time we even
hear the term dotnet is that the
professional developers carve it's the
PDC in Orlando in July of 2000 and
people were surprised actually Microsoft
had been kind of quiet this has been a
tough two years with all the things
going on around the Department of
Justice nobody was really expecting
anything big coming out and so they were
kind of blindsided but interesting part
in the announcement in 2000 this is now
bombers Microsoft he talks about even
then a new platform based on internet
standards and that both c-sharp and the
common language infrastructure would be
published as ACMA specifications and
under the hood this is part of their
negotiation of the Department of Justice
to be a more open company Microsoft is
heading down this path of the what they
called the open source initiative or the
shared source initiative they're not
actually planning on being open source
this is also the time when Steve says
Linux is a cancer but they are making
their source code available to companies
who need it so one of the original
complaints in that whole Department of
Justice trial was that companies like
real networks and Netscape would
complain that their applications didn't
run as well on Windows as Microsoft's
own and that they they believe that
inside Windows there were if Netscape
code and it wasn't true and ultimately
the only way to really prove that was to
make the source code available and so
even back then the source code was
available to companies that showed they
had a need
you couldn't compile it you certainly
couldn't modify it you certainly
couldn't publish it but you could see
and so often that would help them build
better software cuz they can now see how
a witness actually works under the hood
and they could make this improvement so
producing these activist specifications
was part of this negotiation to keep the
if you're being broken up now at the
same time we get Windows 2000 now
Windows 2000 is a very important version
of Windows because this is when the two
lines merged so we'd had the 9x line
from 95 98 98 SC let's not talk about
millennium and then you had the NT line
three one three five three five one four
right the stronger kernel not as nice a
piece of software and here they were
bringing the two together a bunch of
things that happened in 2000 just to get
yourself focused on that era I mean
immediately eighteen years ago this is
the point where Microsoft stock starts
committing to only Intel the NT line up
until now it also supported alpha the
the alpha chip mips chip in the PowerPC
chip but nobody worries using them for
the most part and just wasn't worthwhile
so they finally said it's Intel only
this is also the point where Microsoft
commits to tcp/ip as the primary default
networking stack offered to this point
it had been net Bowie so that's not that
long ago that we are only getting that
sort of stuff figured out but you know
when folks talk about this idea of the
wind tel hegemony arguably it starts
here it doesn't last very long but this
is the point where Microsoft is all-in
on Intel and you know they're building
this version of Windows one of the side
effects of that echo specifications
being published was a very young man by
the name of Miguel de Icaza who add an
O'Reilly conference in 2001 announces
the mono project he won't ship anything
to about 2004 but you know you're
working with volunteers at the beginning
of open source before github and so
forth like these were hard problems to
solve but he builds based on the ACMA
specifications what they called a
cleanroom version of.net eventually we
get the release candidates of dotnet in
2001 at the PDC in Los Angeles we also
get ie6 now they released ie6 a bit
early the CSS specification one had not
been ratified at that point and the real
sin of ie6 is actually at that point the
team essentially dissolved they went to
work on another project a project that
would eventually be codenamed Avalon so
I see six hangs around for a long
time because they also ship Windows XP
we called it Windows 2000 with the
fisher-price interface because it was
very cute it had all curvy bubble shapes
and things it was very nice right it
also didn't support USB at that time you
know that's before any of that stuff and
it came with ie6 but more important in
that year in 2001 with the consolidation
of the operating systems the malware
authors got to work in 2001 you get the
antic Kournikova virus you get code red
one code red to the nimda virus like
there's a lot of hacking going on right
welcome to the Internet
here's your exploited machine and gates
by January 2002 no longer the CEO he's
chief architect publishes a document
called trustworthy computing this is an
internal letter inside of Microsoft
you've done the same thing with the
internet tidal wave where he basically
told Microsoft the Internet's gonna be
important let's focus on that they
trustworthy computing essentially said
everybody stop what you're doing and
work on security we need to solve this
and obviously the focal point of that
was Windows and so with XP having just
shipped service pack 1 is already
planned as is normal when building a big
piece of software there's things that
get cut along the way before you
actually ship those things were all
being pushed onto service pack 1 this
initiative being declared mean they
would make service pack 2 the security
version they were gonna do major fixes
to the security concerns around Windows
for service pack 2 and a non-trivial
chunk of the windows team mostly very
senior people were focused on that
service pack 2 it'll have him it's
important impact on Windows coming up
that's where they're focused we can't
talk about downtown without talk about
Windows and for better or worse because
ultimately when dotnet ships in February
of 2002 its marketing pitches the
corollary or the opposition to Java
Java's pitch had always been any
platform one language and now Microsoft
came with dotnet saying here's 22
languages one platform windows
the real trick is trying to name 22
languages I got the list
it's 22 languages I don't know how many
of these still exist I mean back in the
early days they called it c-sharp net
now they just call it C sharp
there was this C++ not-dead that
virtually nobody is is VB damage kind of
in the same boat J sharp was actually a
bridge for J plus plus developers to
migrate their code into J sharp which is
put it in the runtime model so they
could ultimately move to c-sharp if they
wanted to so i understating care of
folks that have worked on j plus plus
with him and he moved up to the new
version to this day you can still buy
COBOL net it's produced by Fujitsu it's
in the visual studio marketplace if you
have an inclination drop 600 bucks on
COBOL you too can own a copy I BM still
supports a version of Fortran for dotnet
another thing that gets announced at
that same time span in 2002 is a project
called rotor and it was part of the
shared Source Initiative and it was big
chunks of the source code of dotnet
excluding a lot of the windows related
things like a do dot and so forth being
available for academic license so the
original shared source initiative was
for industry only under strict lock and
key with very specific rules they
broadened that with rotor to anybody in
the academic space we wanted to take a
look at dotnet they could have copies
again he couldn't go pilot couldn't
modify it you weren't allowed to share
it but you could have access to all the
source code of dotnet by 2003 we get the
second version of.net which we call 1.1
because numbers are hard and this is
where we sort of get things a little
more mature the bugs are kind of out of
it it's an OK version dotnet but it's
not else reliable we won't really get a
great version of.net until the Virgen
which they'll call version 2 excellent
in 2003 at the PDC the tone of the PDC
changes so the previous two PDC's had
been all about dotnet now it was all
about the next version of Windows so if
you go back and think 95 98 98 SC NT for
Windows 2000 XP Microsoft had shipped an
OS almost every year for
six years and eight they had dominated
the market with XP he was 95% of
workstations ran XP they actually owned
the space and what happens when you're a
market leader well now you can do
whatever you want and so the windows
team which have been happily split up
dealing with the sp2 problems so forth
they start prototyping the next version
of Windows and they kind of go a little
nuts now that was in 2002 and they tie
all that back to a simpler version and
in 2003 at the PDC they talk about the
dial back version so the code name for
XP was whistler now whistler is a ski
mountain not far from where I live
the next ski mountain over is a mountain
called Blackcomb so the original
prototypes for the next version of
Windows after XP were called Blackcomb
but it was this object-oriented monster
that pretty quickly they figured they
were never gonna build so there's like
let's that was back and simplify it well
in between the ski mountain to Whistler
and it scheme out into Blackcomb there
is a bar called the Longhorn bar so it
was Windows Longhorn and in Windows
Longhorn at the PDC no.3 they talked
about the three pillars of Longhorn and
it was Avalon indigo and Wynn FS so a
Balaam was a new visualization system it
was a way for us to have Windows
actually use our GPUs our video cards
properly we had DirectX for years but in
Windows itself it drew directly on the
screen as if the screen was memory bit
bleeding it was inefficient it didn't
take advantage of the hardware the Velo
but pretty much every computer made at
that time now had a proper video card
and so Avalon was how they're going to
bring that to windows Indigo was a
communication set of communication
protocols any kind of communication
between any range machine from within
the process to across the internet would
work essentially the same way fully
configurable and when FS was an option a
file system that was going to allow us
to treat files as if they're objects all
the capabilities it was a great idea
except for the part where it didn't work
anyway by 2004 this has now been three
years since XP shipped
we get service pack 2 of XP and one
could argue if they had only called this
XP version 2 a lot of pain would have
been solved but they wanted everybody to
install SP 2 because it was the security
version it had a lot of fixes in it but
it broke some software which generally
means it should have been called a new
version right service packs azar
supposed to fix bugs but not break
anything new versions can break things
that microsoft so concerned about it
actually getting deployed they call it a
service pack if they had called it
version 2 we wouldn't had some of these
other problems that we have as we move
further along and roughly at the same
time we get studio 2005 so we've gotten
rid of the dotnet moniker it's just
studio 2005 is version 2 of the CLR and
framework I would argue this is the
manifestation of what we always hope for
in dotnet they're very much a strong
enterprise class version of a
development tool this is also when we
get 64-bit support for the first time
this largely caused by AMD AMD came up
with their extension set called x6 x86
64 and a tech dofollow inside of
Microsoft named Dave Cutler published a
paper called windows on Windows
we're explained how in 64-bit mode we'd
be able to run 32-bit apps without any
Signum meaningful modifications through
this thing he called the thunking layer
and it solves the problem my Intel had
been working for years on a process are
called Itanium that was supposed to be
pure 64-bit we ultimately called it I 10
ik because that's how well it's sold
and so when AMD comes up this great
solution for 64-bit intel jumps on board
with their own version called IA 64 are
called am 6040
and there are magic in studio is that
now you can simply compile to 64
although we gave we were given this
great option called compile as any the
idea of compile is any is that the just
italic compiler would simply look at the
OS that you're running on and compile
accordingly now as long as it always
compiled on a 32-bit operating system
you were fine
if you compiled as anyone a 64-bit
operating system it would crash ask me
how I know
there were driver problems it just
didn't work
the Kabbalah said he didn't do what we
needed to do however the other important
thing to happen this version this is
c-sharp 2.0 we get our first versions of
generics and they will have a huge
impact on what happens with dotnet going
forward very important part and it's
exciting that Matz Argos and Don Syme
are here because these are the you know
sign was principal for getting generics
directly into dotnet at this time Mads
will actually come on board in the next
year and we'll start working seriously
on c-sharp microsoft recognizes is they
come out of the consent they're in the
consent decree and so forth they need to
sort of change their look and reach a
larger audience and they make a new
conference called mix the dude in las
vegas and it's about the open web this
is also when they announce their first
new browser IE 7 the guys who've been
working on Avalon finished dealing in
Longhorn and they went back and worked
on a new browser so ie6 to come out in
August of 2001 ie 7 comes out in October
of 2006 why so long the team was
distracted and this is what makes ie6
actually evil and why Safari is now the
new ie6 it was not compliant with
standards and it was popular that's the
sin right if lots of people use it is
not complying to standards and what
happens to web developers when
developers tried to build stuff to
standard and then they have to make an
exception for this popular browsers
occupied with standards which is why
Safari now wins that product that title
so well we eventually purged our lives
of ie6 by just stopping pages from
running on it go get a real browser I
wonder for gonna get there with Safari
again and this happened so what went
wrong
well the first thing is they ran out of
time
what was the time limit time limit was 5
years most large customers are Microsoft
by volume license agreements and the
volume license agreement is not I'm
gonna have 50 copies of office and 100
copies of Windows stood out that ended
up it's only count up your employees
we're gonna set a rate per employee you
get everything
that's how VL a's work and in that VL a
is a snippy
you will get a new OS every five years
and nobody expected to hit that time
limit five years a long time they've
been shipping an OS every year XP ships
November of 2001 Vista ships November of
2006 but only the Enterprise Edition the
version that's stipulated in the volume
License Agreement
has shipped them they don't want to redo
all the volume license agreements and it
ships with non-trivial bucks now these
are a bunch of reasons why these
problems existed they the security model
had changed how drivers work so the
drivers were a complete mess they had
rewritten huge chunks of code that may
not have needed right right like the
networking stacks they so they created a
lot of complexity but they're also
counting on the fact that nobody was
gonna install it because no IT guy
installs of v1 and anything they wait
for the first service back and by the
first service pack may have 2007 it
would all be fixed so who the heck
installed the v1 a Vista product
reviewers cuz it's their job what else
are they gonna do the Paul thoughts Mary
Jo Foley's of the world installed it and
it was broken they had serious problems
and they let the world know my mother
called me and said I don't want any of
this Vista on my computer like I don't
think you're qualified for an opinion
but ok and the damage was done of course
they would fix it up eventually and in
the midst of all this chaos we also in
order to get Vista out the door they
push out things like they get rid of the
three pillars Avalon Indigo they get
shoved back to the dotnet team the
dotnet team calls renames them creative
names like windows presentation
foundation and windows communication
foundation that's also workflow and card
space and I always like card space but
apparently I was the only one so this
was kind of an emergency version of.net
3 Oh didn't change the CLR at all it
just took on all the stuff that had come
out of the long horn fallout and they
were busy trying to integrate that
altogether and at that same time this
thing appears now this is not a good
phone
the original version of this phone was
only to GE for starters like it really
was not that good a phone and it is kind
of the end of phones too I mean after
this phone everything is a slab of flak
last before the iPhone phones were cool
and then tenez and keyboards and they
slid out and after that they're all flat
slabs of black glass so but be that as
it may you know there's a reason
Microsoft's fairly distracted dealing
with that what's happened with the
operating system and trying to find
their way forward on cleaning up the
development environment but that mix
they do mention a new product they
called it Windows presentation
foundation extensions and we did a show
on dotnet Ross with Brad Amos when he
was talking about that and Brad told us
the secret if you want a cool product
name give it a terrible code name if you
have a cool code name like Avalon you
end up with a terrible product named
Windows presentation foundation so his
code name was Windows presentation
foundation extensions and it became
Silverlight much better product name so
this is first announced in December of
2006 ultimately was shipped in September
of 2007 and in since I basically
building an independent runtime for a
subset of dotnet focused on C sharp and
sam'l although the first versions all
the code II was actually in JavaScript
they were really focused on media but it
would run on the Mac so it was kind of a
profound thing and at that time
especially in 2007 the Mac still ran
PowerPC they would switch over to Intel
shortly after that and they made it work
on both versions and they iterated
quickly this is Scott Guthrie in action
and Guthrie was up to something as I've
assembled this timeline I've come to
appreciate
he clearly turns a switch in 2007 he's
now a general manager in dev Dev and he
doesn't like the rate that we're putting
out software and he doesn't and he
thinks that open source is important and
so he starts shipping Silverlight
out-of-band they push out four versions
in the next four updates in like 10
months he also hires Scott Scott
Hanselman Phil hi
and Rob Connery in the same month we
called them
Scott Guthrie's ninja army there were
all these open-source guys and suddenly
they were all in the company at the same
time and the way he recruited them is
they've been working on an alternative
to web forms that we'd eventually know
his MVC and it's an apocryphal story
that's only half true of Scott Guthrie
being invited to a conference in Austin
it was actually the alt dotnet
conference and all thought that was a
movement that really was pressuring this
idea that Microsoft stack developers
should be using more open source there
were good open source solutions out
there that automatically using
everything that Microsoft made was not
necessarily a good choice and he was in
Scott had been invited to attend the
conference to speak at it and he was
gonna do a keynote there and at that
keynote he showed off in public MVC for
the first time testable web development
in front of arguably the ideal audience
for it and caused a furor and so by 2008
actually November 2007 we get studio
2008 this is when the first version of
visual studio team system appears we get
dotnet 3.5 we also get Lync and we also
have the MVC product continuing to come
out of band by 2008 we're kind of an
interesting place now they've done some
fixes to the framework this is three
five one three five sp1 we've got
silverlight up to version two we get the
first public drop of html5 again it's
hard to remember it's only ten years ago
right this is in January of 2008 they
start talking seriously about 2005 we
now have the dotnet 3 framework running
and Silverlight on the Mac so there's
really a version of the CLR it's running
on the Mac mano is now hit version 2 and
is starting to run compared ibly Miguel
de Icaza also announced his own version
of a Linux based version of silverlight
he calls moonlight so he's now
implementing that as well and the MVC
ships in March of 2009 with an
open-source license now because of
lawyers it was a Microsoft public light
which they were roundly crucified for
but it really was a highly permissive
license
it's just that they built their own and
why would you do that and in the midst
of all of that at the PDC in Oh 8 the
new chief architect at Microsoft Ray
Ozzie announces the cloud from the
Microsoft side AWS is already doing its
thing this cloud is called Windows Azure
now the there's a lot of conversation
about you know how Microsoft has many
different large web products and they're
all running on their own infrastructure
we're gonna try and unify that we'll
make that available to you this is the
early days of azure so they have this
concept of the a parole in the web role
it's a very unique programming model but
you know it was the beginning and
Windows gets cleaned up in October of
2009 with a product called Windows 7
which many still feel like is their
favorite version of Windows we actually
get Azure in February of 2010 and chips
with sequel Azure and support for dotnet
Java and PHP again limited set of roles
limits any capabilities but interesting
stuff also in 2010 I literally a month
later the giant iPhone comes along now
this one I think de-stressed Microsoft
more they weren't so sure about the
iPhone but the iPad definitely freaked
them out and it didn't help that a month
after it ships in April of 2010 Steve
Jobs puts on a letter called thoughts on
flash I think it published in The Wall
Street Journal and what he was really
taught you know the text of it was he
was talking about how plugins and
browsers were a vector for malware and
he pointed it flash as an example of you
know bad software that's hurting the
browser now what he was really concerned
about was that flash was killing iPads
it's just a battery eater and he wanted
to eliminate it he didn't want the iPad
to fail because battery wouldn't
alaska's flash
it's 2010 everybody uses flash it's kind
of a big deal he's saying no flash in
Safari but he counted in this malware
terminology it eliminates all plugins
which means it also eliminates
Silverlight as a plugin that's in April
of 2010 said of the height of us loving
Silverlight
there was this new device under iOS and
we just now we knew it wasn't gonna run
uh and proof of Steve Jobs influence by
the end of 2011 Adobe will stop making
flash for mobile I'd like he did drive
it out we got Studio 2010 in March of
2010 our April of 2010 this is the first
product to really implement WPF so
Microsoft had had WPF now around for
almost four years and it's sort of an
orphan they actually integrated as part
of studio they third version of WPF
which they numbered for because numbers
hard actually cleaned up WPF a long way
you know studio pushed it far this is
when f-sharp arrives although the number
at four it's actually the second version
of F sharp which is downloadable
separately from Microsoft Research
because numbers are hard and we get
Silverlight for a real four because was
actually the fourth version which was
our out of browser version of
silverlight and they also supported
chrome which was basically new at this
time as well I would argue the most
important thing in terms of cultural
shift inside of Studio 2010 is that it
shipped with jQuery so here was an open
source tool set and it was actually in
the box with studio it was quite a big
deal and it left the normal jQuery
license in place there had been a push
to say Microsoft should have their own
license on jQuery and smarter people
said don't do that that would be bad and
they actually left the normal license on
jQuery in order to make sure that jQuery
was protected they supported this idea
of a foundation initially called the
jQuery foundation today known as the
JavaScript foundation so specifically
about covering off licensing and
liability around a library that
Microsoft was now directly supporting
contributing to for the developers and
the last PDC happens in October of 2010
so dot studio 2010 out in April October
2010 we see the last PDC it's for the
Microsoft campus it's all streamed
online of a goal
a thousand people went and they were
just an applause track essentially for
the streaming I mean its 2010 so
streaming still pretty new and hip at
that time I know we don't we take it for
granted today but there was an issue
thing that happened at PDC and that was
that there was very little conversation
about Silverlight professional
Developers Conference not talk about
Silverlight and Mary Jo Foley tracked
down a fella by the name of Bob Moglia
who ran server and tools at the time and
said why aren't you talking about
Silverlight and bug Leah said a bunch of
things with the line that was grabbed by
everyone was our strategy has shifted an
ultimately cost him his job he leaves
Microsoft January 28 2011 but the P the
the public's reaction or more
importantly the press's reaction to that
was Silverlight is dead that's not like
Silverlight burst into flames or
anything but the reality was so light
was not gonna run on iOS and they
everybody had an expectation iOS is
going to be important and so literally
their strategy had shifted they were
evaluating whether or not html5
JavaScript which still in early days
it's only 2010 could actually do the job
better and people were not happy now in
2011 we actually have an interesting
time this is the acceleration of
JavaScript so Google was making their v8
JavaScript engine they ran it in chrome
the Fox folks were making a nitro engine
running in Firefox and Microsoft had the
chakra engine that was now shipping in
ie9 and over months in 2011 you saw
rapid iterations of all of these
browsers it was such a friendly
competition they would send each other
cakes when they pushed out a new feature
this is when GPU started being utilized
by browsers and precompilation came in
and JavaScript itself cleaned up became
a tighter smarter more comprehensive
language to the point where people
started talking about running javascript
outside of the browser and we started
seeing what was originally experimental
projects like nodejs become much more
mainstream
I mean noted started back in 2009 but by
2011 with all the improvements in the v8
engine in the chakra engine
you could run really fast server-side
code in JavaScript it was an interesting
space to be thinking about
you're gonna write code on the client in
JavaScript could you write client code
on the server in JavaScript as well and
that brings us to the fall of 2011 so in
September of 2011 top PDC anymore it's
built and it builds they talk about a
new operating system called Windows 8
and it's going to be the tablet
operating system so they have sprinted
from their responsive the iPad to a
version it will take care of all these
things in in 2012 we're gonna have a new
operating system new server and a new
version of studio Studio 2012 that's
gonna allow you to do all the
programming on all this this is also
when the consent decree from 2001
actually ends it originally supposed to
be over five years they've got extended
twice but at 2011 it actually ends now
you're gonna think about where
Microsoft's heads at at this moment they
start talking about JavaScript in such a
serious way this is also where they
announced a thing called wind Jas that
they were providing extensions for
JavaScript programmers to program
against Windows now that anybody did but
they provided them
I pulled the annual report for Microsoft
in 2011 to look at where they were
making their money these are all the
billion dollar businesses that Microsoft
has in 2011 and if you count them up you
realized that all of them with the
exception of three depend on Windows the
three that don't are Xbox which is in
the middle of cleaning up it's red ring
of death so while it grossed more than a
billion dollars is spending like for
Bing which certainly brought in more
than a million dollars why spending more
than two and Skype which is finish they
spend 8 billion dollars buying it so is
it any wonder why Microsoft was doing
everything he could to giving javascript
to Windows and the frustrations that
dotnet couldn't run everywhere that
Silverlight couldn't do all the things
but in the midst of all of that
this guy reappears so Miguel de Icaza
had been doing this thing all along not
only just working on mono but he saw he
loves c-sharp
mom would argue he loves c-sharp more
than just about anybody
and he had built his own versions of
c-sharp and the colluding one that ran
against iOS and called it mano touch and
in 2011 he got one running on Android
called it mano for Android cuz that's a
creative name and right around that time
Attachmate bought Novell and wanted to
shut everything down they thought it was
a waste of money wasn't gonna go
anywhere and Miguel disagreed and he
called his friend nat freeman and they
formed a new company Karl and I were at
billed 2011 and we walked out of that
conference and looked each other and
said what if dotnet didn't Rock because
we make a show cup job that rocks so we
lit up another podcast we lit up the
tablet show it was our contingency plan
we were worried lots of people were
worried the tablet show was going to be
our conversation about cross-platform so
forth we did the show for three years
three years later by 2014 it was
absolutely apparent that dot that's
still rocked and we rolled the show into
the main show and stopped making the
table show separately but I would argue
this was the toughest point in 2011 this
sort of moment at the same time that
Microsoft is focused on JavaScript this
guy showing you can run c-sharp on the
platforms you said you couldn't run
c-sharp on so he kind of creates the
proof point on that but the open source
movement is still going on in Microsoft
in 2012 actually announced this thing
called Microsoft open technologies is in
April 2012 it was nominally promoted as
Microsoft making sure that their
libraries their products worked well
with open source libraries but it also
had a big team of developers behind it
they were contributing to a lotta
different open-source projects typically
again to make it make sure it worked
well against the window stack but it got
broader than that and by the time we get
to studio 2012 we have more open source
libraries involved we get support for
the ARM processors so temporarily
Microsoft went away from Intel and
focused on arm with those lightweight
Windows tablets and we had it available
in studio 2012 so you could actually
all the armed if you wanted to most
people remember studio 2012 for exactly
one thing and that is the all-caps menus
which was a huge crisis people freaking
out about the all-caps minions at bill
2012 when they actually ship win8 and
they've been pushing hard on putting
apps into the window stores 75% of the
apps in the Windows Store at that time
are see sharpens Amal so Microsoft may
not have been that focused on c-sharp
and the dotnet staff but we all were and
we were the one building the apps and so
the message was pretty clear that we
could continue we're gonna continue
working in dotnet where there's a focus
for C sharp focus on Windows or not and
in fact this is pretty much the point
where the focus on Windows starts to
change you know come the companies
technically turned a corner here
although we know may not be aware of it
now we do get a version of studio in
2013 which most importantly gets rid of
the all-caps menus but then Microsoft
renames Azure and they get a new CEO
Satya Nadella
in February 2014 so we've changed
Windows is no longer the center of
Microsoft it's different now and they
start changing names of their products
they make another build in April of 2014
and this is where Rosalyn the new
version of c-sharp is released but it's
released as open source across platform
Andrew's house Berg himself deploys it
unto github on that day the first
version the typescript version 1
actually comes out microsoft announces
that windows will be free on any device
for the screen 9 inches for smaller
windows free there was so much being
announced in April 2012 2014 it was hard
to even get your head around it it was
coming so fast and the dotnet foundation
is formed and they put xamarin and a
bunch of other key products as
open-source projects that should be
supported this is also when in 2014 the
html5 recommendation level finally
actually comes along it's not that long
ago and we get to Studio 2015
this is where we get win 10 we get the
edge browser MS open tech which has only
been around for three years at this
point actually it's just rolled back
into Microsoft because now where they
have been doing all the work on open
source isolated in a separate entity
everybody inside of Microsoft was
working on open source stuff to one
degree or another it's just part of the
company the same way we rolled tablets
show back in the dot and Donna rocks
they rolled there are open source
initiatives back into Microsoft
Microsoft actually takes it all very
seriously and we get Visual Studio code
they rewrite dotnet as an open-source
version quickly to first versions
released since June of 22 2016 it's not
great the second version they call 1.1
is out in March of 2017 with Studio 2017
and the third version numbered version 2
because numbers are hard August to 2017
so what's next well maybe they'll by
github what you're seeing is a
comprehensive shift to the company I
mean the other as much as buying github
is very cool there's a whole of a
conversation to be had by that I think
more relevantly if you look at the
beginning of this year there's not a
Windows group anymore they've broken
windows apart and part of it the client
would they call the client experience
now lives as part of developer division
and the server parts now live in Azure
they're still gonna sell and ship
Windows but they don't recognize Windows
as an independent product by itself it
is a part of a larger holistic whole
Microsoft is more of a of a development
company that it's been since the 80s and
I don't know that we I don't know that
all of Microsoft's comprehend that much
less the rest of us that they have
fundamentally changed their business now
their services business they build
languages and tooling for us to be able
to utilize your services that's the
business today they're less concerned
about licensing software they're more
concerned about providing services we're
just still trying to understand all that
I've been working hard on the past
eighteen months to make this into a book
I'm still probably a year away from
getting it done and I'm still getting my
head around all these things and I hope
you're excited because I certainly am
thank you so much for your time have a
great show